we are in part of the complex an
underground bunker complex underneath
our hotel because the air raid sirens
have sounded it is the the fifth time in
the last about 16 hours I would say
we've managed to get a signal with our
with our our camera and our broadcasting
equipment so we can speak to you but uh
everybody here has been asked to go into
the bunker
um it's becoming part of the routine
here we
[ __ ] down the steps with our body armor
our helmet and then we wait for the Eau
Claire we haven't had the oak there yet
so I'm going to speak to you I'm going
to speak to you here it's part of the
drill as you say yes uh there have been
explosions blast heard in Kiev where you
are in harkheave as well this is the
second largest city in Ukraine very
close to the Russian border intense
fighting there yesterday the Russians
sent in a number of armored columns they
were repulsed we understand that
according to the governor of the region
of parkhaven he has put out a warning
today saying that there will be a curfew
at 3 P.M put into place because he fears
Russian saboteurs are operating in the
city so serious situation there
everybody's got to be inside
by 3 P.M I've been Russian missile
strikes as well particularly serious
incident in the city of chernohev that's
about a three-hour Drive North of where
you are a residential building has been
hit by a missile we understand the lower
two floors in that building are on fire
an unknown number of casualties at the
moment that from the Ukrainian
government's Communication Service
so the threat is here it's real it was
fairly quiet here in denipro but I think
we can say that the last 24 hours
the military campaign the Russian
military campaign not proceeding as they
would have anticipated it is generating
a very serious response particularly
from the European Union that would have
been nobody would have predicted that
we've got people like the Germans now
sending Stinger missiles anti-tank
missiles before this Crisis began they
were offering 5 000 helmets for soldiers
and really quite remarkably I think the
eu's high representative like the
foreign minister the EU now offering to
send fighter jets uh russian-made
fighter jets to the ukrainians the
Ukrainian Pilots know how to use them
um you know it's part of this
extraordinary response that is being
generated from the Russian invasion here